Sheila is with us in Atlanta surely your
question for Anthony and me hi there
Dave and Anthony thanks so much for
listening and helping true family I'll
make this brief I'm in a strange place
right now first bad news well kind of
sort of bad I'm a 54 year old single mom
I've been a Christian since 1978 and
there with my 16 year old son he's a
good kid you've kept the job since you
started working in April 2008 my job
with the phone company closed his doors
and sent our jobs to India so I went
from 55 thousand a year to 11 thousand
year on unemployment I also had another
son but he was murdered in 2012 over an
argument about a girl since that office
closed with the phone company I had been
there long enough to eventually receive
a small pension when I turned 65 of 310
dollars a month
in the meantime I've been doing temp
work as a collector because that's her
job that I had when I was with the phone
company as I went to the Social Security
office one day to get a replacement card
the young lady noticed that I was a 47
year old woman weighing 79 pounds and
she told me or with her suggestion after
that telling her that I was also bipolar
and had a lot of issues going on she
suggested I apply for Social Security
disability which I did and it was at her
suggestion from there but two and a half
years for it to get approved and I
eventually got back pay they just
backdated it from when I applied in 2009
to 2007 okay tap the brakes tap the
brakes Apollo can I help you with today
this is where I'm getting that now I've
been renting my condo for nine years new
property manager came in and said she
was going up on my rent so I looked
around for the apartments they were way
too high I bought a house a foreclosure
for eighty four thousand nine hundred it
was renovated by a lottery winner with
that back pay I put twenty five thousand
as my down payment and that wasn't bad
so I have a $329 $0.17 house note
here's where you come in I have no debt
other than remaining balance on the
house I paid an extra ten thousand to it
in the past three years now and I drop a
ten-year-old call which I paid off into
another question is what I don't have
any credit card debt but due to the fact
that my income my disability is coming
from the government I'm scared to close
my credit card and I'm a real favor
I'd say twenty thousand dollars this
year gotcha okay far away I think she
answered her question Dave cut up the
credit cards you just said you had
twenty thousand dollars in savings
account I don't know what she's scared
for I'm scared the Fed that you're going
to still keep them open but I hearing
your story again I'm so sorry feel sorry
for you know your life situation but
your finance situation I don't know
about you Dave but twenty thousand
dollars on the savings account that's a
good savings account giving all the hell
you've been through you you've really
turned it into something I really have
and so you've done a really good job
managing the pennies that you had right
and with all the whole process you've
been through there so yeah I agree with
you Anthony I don't know why you would
be scared with twenty thousand dollars
in the bank and also I think you need to
look in the mirror and go hey my secret
sauce for my future Sheila is Sheila yes
the Sheila's been doing pretty
dad-blamed good considering what she's
been through
and it wasn't because visa bailed her
out right and so you know you're not
visas not your secret sauce for your
future you're your secret sauce for the
future and that and that's what you lean
on and it is that simple
it really is hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show